one of the films that is nominated for
the academy awards five
times over for best picture best
director best original screenplay and
also
best actress for carrie mulligan who is
in promising young woman
including a terrific cast that uh that
features this man who's on
my show right now on the rich eisen show
the actor christopher mintz ploss how
are you sir
i'm good man how's it going thanks for
having me i'm good how's how's uh how's
it how's it
uh to be involved with some oscar buzz
and a film with some oscar buzz that's
got to be pretty cool
yeah that was a heck of a lead-in and as
you're saying all those categories i was
like i have nothing to do with that
nothing to do with that one hold on a
second hold on a second
hold on a second hold on a second uh
christopher i'm assuming you took
excellent direction
correct absolutely absolutely one day on
set was
incredible uh it was it was a delight to
work with carrie mulligan you know my
five minutes have
nothing to do with why it's nominated
but it's a thrill it is it's really
exciting to be a part of a really cool
project excuse me did you not read your
lines to perfection that's uh in their
best original screenplay
oscar nomination that is christopher
that is very kind of you and i'm going
to let them know and i'm going to make
it a choice to be at the academy awards
this year
there you go what who are you wearing
this year then christopher
i'm going to go a rich eisen t-shirt
ladies and gentlemen oh
no oh yeah hang on a second there's a
lot that's
well no i'm just trying to give away
t-shirts uh
you know i mean this is gonna be great
this will be wonderful so
you'll step up there and but in all
seriousness that's uh
what was it like uh to be you know in a
in this film i know you mentioned it for
folks who may not have seen it that you
are in it for
for a minute uh or or five but uh
your role in this film is just as
integral as anybody else's so
i i give you the floor and what it is
like to to to have been this film
christopher yeah um you know it's it's a
really
heavy and exciting movie to be a part of
if people aren't sure what it's about
you know i think the uh
the short gist of it is a woman tries to
take revenge
on men who take advantage of drunk women
so she goes out and pretends to be drunk
and when the men take her home
she sobers up and tries to have just a
normal conversation of like why are you
doing this
and you know it's it's a character i've
never
really played before which was very
intense to go to set i'm used to you
know getting laughter and all that and
i'm
i'm there kind of molesting a woman it
was very intense
but i think it's got a great message and
yeah it's a really good project to be a
part of
and it's uh again available right now on
blu-ray dvd
and digital nearly all digital platforms
to see
um this uh academy award-nominated film
multiple times over christopher
christopher mintz ploss here on the rich
eisen show so uh you're from the mean
streets of woodland hills california
right christopher is that were you yes
sir from l.a but my dad
is from massachusetts woodster uh
webster massachusetts so i grew up a
boston fan my whole life
so christopher brockman meet christopher
mintz plus speak in my language okay
there you go
so um so so that puts you in in all the
the boston sports categories every last
one of them
yeah yeah socks patriots celtics you
know we've had a good run
but things are happening with all three
of those teams
right now so i'm not really certain
about their future but
i mean you can't complain we've won way
too many championships in the past 20
years understood
way to spike the football there so what
was it like to watch you
uh to for you to watch tom brady do it
for somebody else
what about that i loved it man i'm a
full-on i realized when that switch
happened that i'm a massive tom brady
fan you know i was i think i was
11 when i saw him win his first super
bowl so i grew up watching him
so i was like go win it go win it
elsewhere man i support him 100
so it wasn't sort of uh fear of missing
out there was no fomo of watching
tom do his thing no no i felt like a
buck fan the whole season honestly and
you know with covid and everything going
on it was a weird year and patriots had
like
six defensive guys sit out so it kind of
felt just like all right we'll take the
year off and just go
for tom okay so now what do you think
about what uh belichick and the team
should do
right now having re-signed cam newton i
mean it feels like you know they filled
a bunch of gaps that they needed they
didn't sign like any crazy
superstar players but they got a couple
great tight ends they got a bunch of
their own
defensive players coming back so i feel
like you know i feel like a wild card
spot is in play
well i know you were offering to wear a
rich eyes and show t-shirt to the
academy awards that you may or may not
truly actually be planning on attending
um but this is i do believe your first
rodeo of calling into the show appearing
on this program and i'm pleased to have
you here
uh we have a segment called higher
register where you have to go
where when you speak in higher register
that means you have to go
higher register to believe what you're
saying you do realize you went
higher register when i asked you how the
patriots look and you said they look
good you went higher register you went
like
they look good like you actually they
look good
exactly that's good
i mean they do they look good there we
go there we go
that's what i'm saying he said it with
his chest that's what i'm saying
good they're not gonna you know they
don't look great what can i say but you
gotta believe belichick knows what he's
doing and
he signed a bunch of solid role players
okay uh have you ever
in your in your endeavors come across a
patriot player or red sock player
anybody like that who has seen your work
and you have compared notes in any way
shape or form has that happened yeah
i've been very lucky to go back to
boston a bunch of times
i you know i've had dinner with rondo
back in peak rondo
championship celtics era okay same with
kevin garnett paul pierce
um i partied with gronkowski
and his hands are freaking massive um
and he had a few women with him as well
um okay and i met mookie betts when he
was a red sox which i think is one of
the most
brutal moves in red sox history was
letting
that guy go for sure well i'm sure you
growing up here in los angeles you have
a lot of dodger friends who are probably
giving you crap for thanks for mookie
bets
right i'm sure yeah yeah and i think i'm
too good of a friend while it's like
well if he's gonna go anywhere i'm glad
he went to my best friend's team so they
get to watch him but it stings
it stings for sure so you know so it's
been a while since you've hung with paul
pierce because i didn't see you in his
instagram live video that made the
rounds
chris i didn't get the invite i was
really bummed about that one
you're not in his poker group is that
what you're saying i guess not i gotta
find a way to get in there though it
looks like a grand old time for sure
we're on that list as well i'm also
unemployed right now so i have no job
to lose like he did okay so
you you only live once though right so
you gotta yolo and see if we can get you
into paul pierce's uh
circle inner outer or whatever i mean
yeah i mean if
you're gonna be there rich i'm in i
don't know um
i do have multiple jobs and a wife uh
and
children so i don't know you know
uh i don't i don't know i don't think uh
to be
but here here's my one in here he said
that he loves shabbat
so i've got that going for me uh being a
fellow
jewish lover of shabbat um yeah maybe i
could tell the shabbat tell your wife
the shabbat is going from 9 p.m to 4 a.m
time i got to take notes
on this these are great things to write
down i got uh christopher mintz ploss
here
on the rich eisen show okay i i do have
a couple of questions about your
your previous work um and we have we
have a segment here called celebrity
true or false
where we take some items from the
internet which we know can be a little
bit dicey and ask uh
ask you if you can give us the the
higher or nay sign on on whether
something's true or false would you mind
going down that road okay mike del tupo
hit it a little production value right
here
celebrity true or false you can't handle
the truth
all right very good right there so
that's uh set up for christopher mintz
plos
true or false um did you like our our
our
production value set up right there
chris loved it got me amp
ready to go thank you for playing along
with this
all right first up here don bowie if you
wouldn't mind uh putting it up right
here
your first scene in the movie superbad
your film debut
was improvised the scene in the cooking
class at school was totally improvised
that true is that true or false your
first line
your first scene oh that is uh
that is improvised it is yeah
okay because yeah you see see your
first line what up gangsters was totally
improvised
oh one of gangsters might not have been
but the chicka chicka yeah that comes
right after was
was just top-notch improvisation okay
who could think of such a brilliant line
such as chicka
where did that come from christopher uh
just being a fool just being 17 years
old and being a fool
okay and so was there was there how did
you get involved with the film to begin
with
how did that happen uh they were looking
they had auditioned a bunch of
uh legitimate actors at the time because
at the time i was in high school
and hadn't pursued the career just yet
uh but they couldn't find anyone so they
emailed a bunch of drama departments
throughout
lausd and me and my buddies heard about
it because we're in drama class and we
both just went out
and you know i i went in and did a great
job apparently
was was rogan there seth rogen there was
everybody involved in that
he was in the third callback uh i went
in once just for the casting director i
went in another time for the director
and then the third time i went and it
was with everyone
and i genuinely didn't think i was going
to get the part so i brought the script
in had
everybody sign it and i walked out i was
like oh that was a nice little
experience and then
a little little do i know it changed my
whole life where does that where's that
signed script now
it's at my parents place actually they
still got it wow
yeah i mean i mean that that's gotta i
mean that's gotta get you into paul
pierce poker event at least
yeah if things go south for my career i
could sell that for 300.
so you got that going for you as a
backstab all right second one uh
because you were only 17 at the time you
were the youngest main cast member
your mom had to be on set for all your
scenes including your sex scene in the
movie is that a true story
she did not have to be there for every
scene but she 100 percent had to be
there for the sex scene
absolutely okay so
um was that that had to be weird
i mean i guess that was the way i have
to phrase the the the question
to you all right definitely
uncomfortable when you're you know at
the time
i was actually a virgin so i had no idea
what i was doing i was very nervous
very scared and then i look over at
video village and my mom is eating like
a handful of popcorn talking to the
producers
this is very very surreal very very
surreal
so she was casual about it is what
you're saying yeah she was having the
time of her life
absolutely so she's challenging a little
bit of craft services in the video
village and you're and you're
and you're sweating it out essentially
yeah she really
she won that day for her i don't know i
think you won the day too
deep down when you just put it all
together uh so for also for the movie
kick ass which i have seen with my
children they love it
uh you were required to drive stick
shift and after the movie you completely
forgot how to do it is that true
absolutely very true i did not know how
to drive it prior to the movie
i had to learn the car costed 200 000
uh and i thought i was going to crash it
and oh my whole paycheck
and then afterwards i completely forgot
as well so wait a minute so if you blew
out the transmission because you didn't
know how to drive stick which by the way
i don't either
um it would have come out they would
have garnished your wages if you had
blown out the transmission on all that
is that true i don't think so but that's
what the director would threaten
and once again i was 20 years old so i
was very impressionable
so i you know i i believed them i did my
job
okay and and uh last one for you i'll
just audible this one
uh are you fine are you cool with the
fact that dan patrick
uh has a danette uh andrew perloff go by
mclovin are you fine with that or do
you or do you have an issue certainly
with uh andrew's takes on sports to be
associated with him in any way shape or
form
well so i've never actually seen or
heard the show i'm very flattered they
have a character i think that's really
cool
uh but i guess i should ask you guys is
he doing some ridiculous takes should i
not want to be associated well
here's the thing is he is just a
dynamite human
okay let's we start we start with the
basic facts
that on planet earth he is a a force of
good
not evil love it he is he is a family
man
he is a professional a lead pipe
wielding professional
but his sports takes are some of the
worst takes i have ever heard
can you give me one can you give me one
take oh sure
you know like just he's had just a
couple in the last in
the last few days recently he called
uh he wondered if if ohtani of the
angels was
was like the uh the taysom hill of
baseball
and you know as we know taysom hill
we've seen people throw and pass and run
like
ohtani's a unicorn so that was yeah that
was kind of a
i just literally just scratched my head
on that one right
he's it sounds like a stick it sounds
like he knows exactly what he's saying
he knows it's outrageous i think it's 50
50. i think it's 50 50. i think he
really believes this they have a segment
called against the grain because
everything he says is kind of like
against the grain of what normal people
would think about sports christopher
uh yeah yeah i gotta i gotta get rid of
that mclovin name over there man
he's also hardcore philadelphia too so
that kind of oh boy
dude you really think so i don't know
you know
do we have another one right here maybe
if i got one in the shoe you're
basically saying that
that sam don't say if sam darnold
succeeds with carolina then it just
shows you that the jets didn't do
right by him and it's just like yeah i i
get that
yeah you know what yeah see what i'm
saying yeah the jets have been in
shambles though like that's
that's just been known yeah that's a
weird oh my god i just went to that way
with a patriot fan i just kind of just
walked
i just walked right into that hey
christopher congrat congrats on
everything with promising young woman
again everyone should go see it um and
um
and let's do this more often here on
this show i appreciate it guys
i'm a big fan it's awesome to come on
thank you for having me and uh i'll talk
to you guys soon are you
a size large on a t-shirt is that what
it is i'm a medium i would please send
me everything you got
you're a medium my god god bless you
eating right get ready for a gigantic
care package
from us have you seen any of my movies
because i am i look like i'm 90 pounds
in all of them i know that i know that
but you're you're now
a 31 year old man so yeah yeah the
metabolism is slowing out a little bit
i'm up to 100 pounds
god bless you god bless you all right
christopher thanks for the call really
appreciate it you'd be welcome
guys thank you very much it's
christopher mintz plos right here on the
rich eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here